hi there steve kaufman here uh i think i
started my um 90-day challenge uh korean
challenge on the 10th
of september so it's got to be around
the 15th day here i'm sorry i didn't
give i didn't put up a video yesterday
or the day before friday was busy my
wife had her operation i didn't get out
to the hockey game because she wasn't
released until 1 30. i was there ready
to go at 10 30 to take her home and rush
off to the game we lost as a result we
played in the uh bronze medal game
instead of the gold medal game we won
the bronze medal
we won eight to one
very proud of ourselves
um
and most of my korean activity has
consisted of listening as i drive to and
from different things
listening in the car and then
reading on link
what has happened is
these wonderful
podcasts that i discovered with
transcript
they're very interesting because they're
very up to date on things that are
happening in korea so i'm listening to
discussions people who are debating
debating in a very i kind of like the
way the koreans discuss things very
uh sort of uh calm it seems uh
and they talk about
for example the deployment of the
anti-missile system in korea known as
t-h-a-d-d or saad
in korean at first i didn't know what
this was i had to look it up in
in google not google translate but
google to find out
what this was
and so i'm learning a lot about korea so
it's very interesting so now i'm
actually in a situation where i don't
want to leave my career normally i found
that i didn't have interesting content i
was easily distracted away to polish or
russian now i'm really getting into this
korean stuff and i understand it when i
read it because of course i have my
links i can look up words
uh i don't understand solo when i listen
to the podcast
but i have a much better sense of how
the language works and structures that
struck me as strange before that that
even if i knew the words i couldn't
figure out what they were trying to say
now the language flows quite nicely for
me i've kind of caught up to the rhythm
of the language and in so far structures
are concerned i still have missing words
i still have trouble understanding when
i listen but i'm i feel definitely that
i'm gaining on the language and i know
from experience that if i do enough
reading
at some point the the listening
comprehension
is going to click in so i'm very happy
with my career right now i feel i'm
gaining on it i've got interesting
content
uh and so but now i have to tear myself
away at least briefly because
uh on wednesday i'm doing a seminar a
webinar in german
uh for a teacher that contacted me and
she teaches german teachers and so i'm
going to talk a little bit about um you
know language learning and link in
german and i'm going to leave a link to
that webinar if anybody who understands
german wants to attend they can simply
join in it's uh
adobe connect platform but i think there
will be room for quite a few people to
come and join so then the issue for me
is do i
say because normally if i'm going to be
speaking german which i don't speak i
mean once or twice a year i'll maybe
spend a day or so listening and linking
and reading and trying to bring my
german up to
speed but i'm reluctant to vote to
devote the time to german i want to stay
with my korean which is a nice feeling
because previously i've always been
forcing myself to stay with korean and
when i really wanted to do some other
language
uh one other thing someone asked you
know why do you need so many words like
my korean word count is now approaching
36 37 000 words uh lots of people have
eight or ten thousand words and they say
they're fluent uh first of all korean
has a lot of different forms of the same
word so it's possible that
people with 8 000 words are talking
about word families
that's one thing and the other thing is
it depends what you want to do with the
language i want to understand these
political discussions i want to
understand what's happening in korea i
want to watch movies i want to cover a
lot of different things therefore i need
a lot of words
if you
just want to be able to say some things
and have more limited conversations
obviously you don't need so many words
however
as i've said before i believe the word
counted link and the reason why i've
said that when i get to 50 000 words in
the language normally i'm normally i'm
under able to understand quite well
the reason is that
using link in order to get to 40 or 50
000 words i have to have listened to a
lot and read a lot so that the
known words count is almost like a
milestone of how much time how much
activity i have spent with the language
and ultimately language learning is
about the amount of time you spend
actively engaged with the language and
that's why a high word count the way we
counted that link
is an indication of just how active
you've been with a language
so that's on that score my wife is fine
for those who asked the operation went
fine now she has to take these
painkillers for a little while as the
pain in the foot
gradually subsides
and she's of course immobile i can't put
any weight on the foot you get
surrounded with crutches i do all the
cooking and uh but
things are fine all done on
the medical system free of charge and
i'm a great believer in universal
medical care not necessarily that canada
has the most efficient form of it i
think there are better ones in france i
think where the system is more flexible
but the principle that everyone in the
country is covered i think is a good one
anyway thanks for listening bye for now